The next kind of software testing that I want to talk about is integration testing.
Integration testing refers to taking multiple software modules
that have already been unit tested and testing them in combination with each other.
At this point often what we're really testing
are the interfaces between modules,
and the question is did we define them tightly enough
and specify them tightly enough that the different people
or the different groups of people implementing the different modules
were able to make compatible assumptions,
which are necessary for the software modules to all actually work together.
And it often turns out that during integration testing
we find substantial differences of assumption
that have to be resolved before we can create a reliable
integration of the individual parts.
And so as a computer science professor, what I find
is that groups of students are almost always successful
at creating well-tested, reliable software modules,
but that separate groups of students who individually
create software modules, even when implementing to a fairly tight specification,
often create software modules that fail under integration testing.
It's really something that's quite a lot harder to do.
Coming up with a software module that survives integration testing
is really quite a lot harder often than creating reliable small units.